We are taking calls via discord at
David Pakman dotcom slash discord.
Let's talk to a few other people at least. Why
don't we go to let's go to Ben from Boston,
Ben from Boston. You're on the air.
Oh, hey.
Did you just call like a minute ago, I just
clicked on the but I can I can barely hear you.
You're going to have to get much closer to your
microphone or something. And I called on you. Now,
I don't know. It sounded like you were
asking if I previously called on you.
I called on you. Now, there was a different Ben.
I tried calling on before, but it wasn't you.
Thank you. That makes a lot more sense.
Is this better? It's a little
better, yeah. Go ahead.
So I was just wondering your take on kind of going
forward with what should the mainstream media
kind of do to kind of quell some of
this division that my dad is actually
a sports journalist for many, many years
in the past, and he's always told me about
that. A lot of this partizanship kind of
started when the you've heard of this like
the Fairness Doctrine, the FCC, this doctrine
that basically mandated that there had to be
both sides of, you know, both sides of an argument
to be presented. There was sort of limited number
of channels and they wanted that certain channels
to have be a left leaning perspective and the
right leaning just have airtime on both sides.
And I think Reagan ended that practice. And my
dad always tells me that, you know, he thinks that
a lot of this kind of division and polarization in
the news is starting to run around them. So I was
just wondering what your take on that. And and and
perhaps also, you know, I wondered if a lot of
people don't understand the difference between,
let's say, like news and opinion. Yes. And
maybe there should be better regulation.
I think regulation. So regulation is stuff that's
that's a lot. So let me let me deal with that,
because that's a lot of stuff, people. The
second part is a media lack of media literacy.
I've addressed that before. We need to be teaching
media literacy, starting two to 11 year olds, even
younger, being able to identify the difference
between content and advertising, which really
young kids can't do, which is why advertising to
children is so pernicious. The difference between
news and opinion, that's a we have a huge media
literacy issue in the country. But the first issue
is very interesting. I think at this point there
are people who say we need a new fairness doctrine
at this point. I believe that practically
speaking, because so much of the information
people are getting is on the Internet, it seems to
me that a new Fairness Doctrine would be a Pyrrhic
victory in the sense that you might throw huge
amounts of struggle and chaos, get something done,
and it would be of minimal value because the
media landscape has just changed dramatically.
It's not about limited airwaves that have
to be divided fairly in a certain way.
It's a totally different situation with
people getting news from the Internet. So
I don't think that the regulatory approach
in terms of a new fairness doctrine is the
right approach. I think it's a we need a cultural
educational realignment that teaches people to be
more savvy when it comes to the information that
that they consume. I feel strongly that that's
the right approach and that a new fairness
doctrine would not really be what we need.
Thank you. My pleasure. Great to hear
from you. Let's take a very quick break.
If you're holding, don't
hang up, because we're going
right back to the phones momentarily. The
David Pakman Show at David Pakman Dotcom.